ja ich dachte mir gibt bestimmt
ernsthafte demir und vielleicht streit
und ich bringe mal was nettes und die
grünen haben gestern domino gespielt und
soll das wenn man das so aufbaut und 1
nachdem nacheinander gibt es ist ja
glaube ich schon mitbekommen dass ein
mensch mit migrationshintergrund in die
regierung geschafft hast du mir das eine
gute nachricht ist nämlich einer der
besten in die guten haben ist allerdings
ein vegetarier im großstadt wahlkreis
der jetzt für ackerbau und viehzucht
zuständig ist aber egal aber das
interessante richtlinie kam in die
regierung ein realo man dafür flog der
flinke mann anton hofreiter raus weil
ein linker man ausflug muss aber auch
eine rechte frau raus liegen nämlich
katrin göring eckardt die schon als
familienministerin gebucht war dafür kam
anna spiegel ins familienministerium was
wiederum auslöste dass ich weitere
grafik mitbringen soll dass eine linke
frau umweltministerin wird nämlich
steffi lemke und wenn sie sich jetzt
fragen warum dann eine reale linke ist
ostdeutsch das muss ich unbedingt dazu
kommen durcheinander also eine
ostdeutsche wird umweltministerin und
jetzt darf claudia roth eine
westdeutsche linke ins kanzleramt
kulturstaatsministerin und das endspiel
ist mit den staatssekretären und seiner
in drei jahren besetzen die grünen den
posten des nächsten deutschen
eu-kommissars steht auch im vertrag und
nach der logik muss dass ein
ostdeutscher realo mit
migrationshintergrund werden also schon
wieder drei jahre so nicht stehen aber
darf ich mal eine zwischenfrage stellen
finden sie das denn jetzt besser dass in
der fdp nur männer aus westdeutschland
das sagen haben warum ja nur eine frau
genau aber sonst nur männer und alle aus
westdeutschland und kein einziger mit
migrationshintergrund ist das jetzt gut
soll dass die zukunft deutschlands event
super abschreibungen die sie so hassen
wenn du jetzt nicht von christian
lindner sondern davon mehmet lindner
eingeschult werden haben sie dann dafür
es geht doch um die politik
das sind jetzt völlig falsch weil
gleichberechtigung ist wenn auch frauen
ostdeutsche migranten fehler machen
dürfen nicht aber irgendwann einmal
umsetzen
unser system ist so wie sie die fdp
nur westdeutsche männer haben ernsthaft
eine chance an der macht zu sein und
dann da auch um eine frage
überhaupt seite zwei stellen wir die
frage warum kümmert sich erste mir um
puten und bio borkum putin können sie
mir das erklären dass wir nicht übrigens
eine frauenfeindliche warum
weilburg hat er letztlich der gesamte
studium mit außenpolitischen themen
verbracht das heißt sie ist und warum
ist
nein aber sie hat auch in brüssel und so
weiter letztlich immer außenpolitik
gemacht das heißt sie kennst du den
außenpolitik aus jetzt zu sagen sie
seien nicht kompetent
er hat auch außenpolitische erfahrung
ist leider nicht irgendwie ein bisschen
schlau bin
ich schon ein
wir müssen die christian linder toll
finden wenn wir über studium reden weil
christian lindner hat nämlich seine
magisterarbeit über
steuerwettbewerb und finanzausgleich die
fragestellung kann die finanzverfassung
reform abschreibungen hat auch nicht
aufgepasst also ich würde sagen dann ist
ja auch dafür
also ich selber bin ja auch bankkauffrau
aber wenn man jetzt schon den titel
dieser arbeit liest weiß man dass es
neoliberal war und insofern passt also
dass es böse oder das ist eine sage mal
so eine klassische ausrichtung zum thema
steuern und in seine super abschreibung
für unternehmer passt genau zu seiner
magisterarbeit das ist alles was ich
sagen muss ich habe dein blick auf die
grünen wie die räder verteilt haben
nein ich war schon dass sich die runde
etwas beruhigt hatte hab da so intensiv
diskutiert habt euch richtig ineinander
fragt als schweizer bin ich natürlich
ein diversity spezialist nicht wahr wir
haben ja die vielfalt schon ganz tief
drin und vor dem hintergrund unserer
diskussion muss ich sagen dort trieben
diversity draufsteht alexanders oft eben
gar nicht city drin und diversity ist
richtig froh braucht in einem kabinett
meinungsverschiedenheit nach der
diskussion der von frau herman die am
meer oder weniger fast schon das
kommunistische manifest ihr vorgetragen
ich sage es ist leicht ironische
übertrieben gewesen wieder sagen es
braucht dort unbedingt diesem kabinett
ein paar reiche unternehmer die frau
herrmann erklären das unternehmen zum
beispiel auch löhne bezahlen mit diesen
löhnen bezahlen dann auch die
angestellten ihre steuern das heißt ohne
die unternehmer haben sie keine steuern
in deutschland außer sie machen sollten
und das ist natürlich ein ganz wichtiger
ökonomischer zusammenhang den ihrem
sonst so scharfen verstand ihr entgangen
ist ich würde gerne antworten dass die
unternehmen aber nur unternehmen können
weil sie die vielen angestellten haben
also ohne die arbeit beschweren dass die
angestellte und löhne bekommen von den
bischöfen er ja aber das tun sie ja
nicht in einem luftleeren raum nicht
ganz wichtig zum beispiel sind die erst
etwas weltanschaulich heute
bei ganz grundsätzliche fragen
auf den punkt
ja genau ich wollte doch nur ein spaß
machen
geht das oder ist das jetzt sozusagen
ein fehlstart die haben sich um die
posten gekloppt keiner weiß wer da jetzt
wütend ich las heute in einem diversity
fachblatt nämlich nicht vorher man auch
arbeitet und da erstand das alles super
erklärt und anstatt einmal runter jetzt
werden die flügel reaktiviert bei den
grünen und dass seine organisation um
vergeltungsmaßnahmen
organisieren und da muss man muss
muss man sich ja dann fällt der nächste
realo irgendwo durch wahrscheinlich aber
wo denn dann also ich hab bei der
nächsten wahl und also wir beide posten
absprachen erfahren wir ja immer nur die
minister aber diese posten bis die geht
runter bis parlamentarische
staatssekretäre nächster chef von
irgendeiner bundesbehörde also da kann
man vielen leuten noch viel werten
letzte frage zu dem thema hat frau
göring-eckardt irgendeine chance noch
bundespräsidentin zu werden woher man
keine chance das ist für sie persönlich
auch sehr traurig weil sie dachte monate
lang regiert ist und dann dachte sie
jetzt wochenlang sind mit
familienministerin und jetzt muss sie
weiterhin fraktionschefin bleiben oder
und nach
sie kann ja jetzt parlaments
vizepräsidentin werden
dann sie dann ihr volk ein cookie
mittelbar die freundlich oder folgerung
ärgert aber sie sitzt auch nebeneinander
so das stimmt ja die die die spd hat das
denn genau so gelöst haben den ersten
posten mit einer migrantischen frau
besetzt und jetzt kann scholz schalten
und walten wie er will und